so here's the idea right um you get
something and of course you guys know
the algebra how to complete the square
right but it's a picture it's a picture
imagine there's a picture there right so
x squared literally means it's a square
and cycling X yes sir something like
authorities X by X so that's what makes
this x squared okay and what you're
adding to that is something which is
what EDX is what it might be a square
but a midol be it's definitely a
rectangle sometimes right inside like X
+ 10 is out of capability so I'll draw
like this I guess can you see so same
side length right that make sense okay
and then you've got you may be a real
Saturnia now right and then you've got
some other thing over here which is like
I don't know 39
whoever do this it's like a flop square
okay so it's pretty nice liquid like I
can't do anything meaningful 39 at least
nothing that necessary no to this but
you guys know okay to complete the
square
what you do is you is you have this
number and you square that right but
where does that come from and the answer
is it's you take this thing and I want
to do it onto this so I get a square out
of it right so what I'm going to do to
this is I'm going to slice it in half
like so I'm going to say well if I got
like half but here half here this length
is not going to be ten here for you it's
going to be fine five do you do that
right so what I've got really like the
way do you want the way to complete the
square is to say well just divide this
thing up into two okay now the reason
why a t-score is because geometrically
you can say where horrors happen if this
thing is x squared that means this
length and these things are the same
yes okay so the the sort of mind-blowing
thing for me anywhere happened when you
say okay take this guy and just move him
everything up right so that's five and
that's X and then take this guy and turn
you around so that if it's on like this
because remember the length is X right
all right and then you like aha like
this shake you only have to do something
meaningful with this what do I need to
add on in water to make oh I should
square it what I did so you have on 25
yeah that's right
see you like oh this is x squared plus
2x the reason I carve is so I can do
this construction and then the reason I
Sperry so I can complete the square
right then of course what you cover the
other side we did you just put them
together that's then everybody but
that's also I are square and right so
now look at this we can see what is the
side length of the square and the answer
is it's X plus 5 X plus 5 that's why
it's a perfect square because it's a
square headed right and then and then of
course you go ahead and solve right and
so now you see like what why didn't
anyone tell me this I was fooling around
with the algebra another oh I guess it's
kind of cool right and yeah yeah it's
just um you need things like that right
and then they help you they help
students appreciate why completing the
square is not just some or good thing
that gets me the korky project women are
actually and we always should have
guessed by the name right it's just a
beautiful construction